[Music]  hello  sid it's happening  three attacks so far  whatever his link is to our past it ends  here  i've seen this for me before not this  movie sydney  [Music]  rated r  [Music]  this isn't funny amber when you like to  play a game tara  [Laughter]  all doors locked  doors unlocked  hello  it's happening  three attacks so far do you have a gun  i'm sydney prescott of course i have a  gun  something about this one just feels  different  samantha  i'm i know who you are i've been through  this  a lot  this is your life now which means that  whoever this is is going to keep coming  for you  [Music]  you ready  for this  never oh  there are certain rules to surviving  the attacks were all on people related  to the original killers  whatever his link is to our past  it's pulled us all back here  and i won't sleep until he's in the  ground  hello sydney  it's an honor  [Music]